Mm,
well they did a show called the eyes of
Nye
companies like Monsanto had patents on
genes and people were questioning
whether or not that was ethical.
Also,
there was this overarching idea that we
have enough food,
we just can't distribute it properly,
and the reason people are starving in
the world is there's enough food.
In my concern was the ecosystem.
The sisters say,
you can know each organism very well and
by no I mean you can know it's the
sequence of its genes and you can grow
it in isolation and refuges and see how
it performs.
This term had crops.
Now,
there would be no need to experiment
with the ecosystem even though you can
know the individual crop plant,
you don't know what it would do.
One,
it's around butterflies or bees or birds
or other pollinators or some virus we
haven't discovered yet.
Since then,
a couple of things.
Three things have happened to my way of
thinking.
The,
uh,
the least significant may be that we can
now ask,
say genes 10 million.
This is to say no.
One hundred million,
10 to the eighth time's faster than we
could 15 or 20 years ago.
The DNA sequencing machines are so
sophisticated,
you can actually simulate what would
happen if this virus comes in or that
gene is introduced from a vector or an
insect vector or what have you.
That's the first thing that you can make
predictions about how plants will grow
based on their genes very accurately,
much more so than you could a couple of
decades ago.
The second thing is there are seven
point 3 billion people in the world
right now,
early in the 20,
20,
first century.
By the middle of the 21st century.
This is going to be 9 billion.
There might even be 10 billion people.
So those people are going to have to be
fed.
And sure enough,
uh,
the way to do that is almost certainly
with genetically modified crops,
which are much more productive than they
used to be.
And then from a historic standpoint,
humans have always hybridized crops,
but now a humans are hybridizing them
from a genetic standpoint,
not just by combining sexually,
uh,
crops of desirable traits.
And the third thing that was very
compelling to me as a scientist is we've
discovered,
and maybe everybody knew this except me,
and I'm the first one that we've
discovered that genes are introduced
between species naturally.
And the paper that really got to me was
the one about sweet potatoes.
So sweet potatoes became sweet potatoes
because something like a virus infected
the sweet potatoes and changed their
genes.
And then humans cultivated those gene
changed potatoes.
And so without this introduction of
inter species between species genetic
transfer,
this wouldn't have happened.
So this,
these three things,
the ecosystem concern,
the rate at which we can ask,
say genes,
the number of people that are going to
have to be fed.
That's the second one.
And the third one is it happens
naturally anyway.
Uh,
these three things have changed my point
of view about genetically modified foods
and the regulations for them are
actually quite robust.
You can't just go creating a crop plant
that's going to be deleterious to the
farming system along with this,
everybody first to admit,
uh,
the idea that you can,
that you can patent genes seems
troubling.
But there's a little bit,
there's a lot to it that's very
reasonable.
Companies like pioneer seed company
that's part of dupont and the be mixed
feelings.
Monsanto,
they spend a lot of money,
a huge fraction of their resources on
developing these plants.
And recently the patented soybean
expire.
The patent expired.
So soybeans are out now.
So,
okay,
so if you want to grow those soybeans,
now you can.
And uh,
farmers do make contracts to grow those
plants because they grow better.
So what we can imagine a future where
plants are tuned to grow in very moist
soils at the bottom of the hill where
the water runs down very dry soils at
the top of the hill where the water
drains away quickly and in between.
And the plants that would be planted,
the crop plants that will be planted
would vary like meter to meter,
certainly old crow across the farm
field.
They would vary from one end to the
other and they would be planted
electronically using global positioning
from outer space.
And this will enable people to feed the
world.
So,
uh,
I used to be against genetically
modified foods just for,
from the cautionary principle,
you don't know what you're doing in the
ecosystem.
So be careful now I am for genetically
modified foods because we have so much
more science behind it than we did even
20 years ago.